guys robert pattinson's a fraud ah he's
a fan
he's a fat phony he faked the
coronavirus test
the batman's in trouble because of him
he's got no muscles
damn it okay so i read the headline
now before we dive into this i really
want to do this just because of how
ridiculous this sounds
we haven't even dissected the article
and i'm telling you
i don't believe this this sounds like a
very very
now story sometimes i just like covering
a movie news story that just sounds like
a
fun thing to talk about even if i
already have sold myself that i don't
believe
i'll keep an open mind let's see what
sources are pulled here
let's see what is uh unveiled maybe
there will be something here
to change my skepticism to this
ridiculous title get ready to eat some
crow but come on let's talk about it it
could be fun
two sources have come out and stated
that there are big problems surrounding
the batman
with claims that robert pattinson may
have faked the coronavirus and that the
actor is
butting heads with director matt reeves
which is causing
massive issues with production
doom [ __ ] of the overlord dvd youtube
channel
you know you know it's a good story when
it's coming from this guy
was the first to claim that the batman
movie is in deep trouble with midnight's
edge youtube channel confirming doom
cock's info through uk director and
writer gary j tunicliff hey
gary why why that reaction
uh he is the head of a uh makeup effects
studio called two hours in the dark
and i've actually worked with him in the
past well then everything he has to say
must be true
gist of claims of the problems and
trouble has to do with robert pattinson
not wanting to work out which has led to
a big conflict with director matt reeves
oh really
he's a big fitness geek feels the
stuntman used for filming will look a
lot bigger than pattinson
who was supposed to work out but has
chosen not to wait a minute they've
already shot
here's here's why i don't believe here's
why i'm already thinking i don't believe
this
because we already got a teaser trailer
for it where you see images
of robert pattinson and stuntman in bat
suit i'm assuming some of those have to
be the stunt man right
well i'm fine there and one would only
assume that the stunt men's suit would
probably be made out of a slightly
different
material and if the actor is not quite
the same body type there are ways to
compensate for that
you would think this problem would have
arisen then
yeah before shooting any of that awesome
footage that we got regarding robert
pattinson the coronavirus it's claimed
to be a cover story to cover that reeves
shut down production in order to give
pattinson time to work out
who refused yet to get he robert
pattinson is such a committed
actor with his director i doubt he would
be this
adamant about it the batman has long
been known to be a troubled production
says doomcock there have been multiple
shutdowns
allegations of coronavirus infections on
set
whispers of problems with robert
pattinson's attitude in short
productions of the film
has been an absolute disaster the batman
is in deep [ __ ]
and may even be delayed again with
another forced shutdown
it's by marvel marvel's making all this
happen and marvel and marvel's jealous
marvel gave
patterns in the coronavirus my source
alleges that all of that was a lie
that robert pattinson being sick was a
load of bvs a cover story to hide the
real reason
matthew reeves wanted to shut the
production
down when pattinson showed up for the
first day of shooting the director took
one look at him and lost his [ __ ]
pattinson was supposed to be working out
during the
john campion somewhere as having a field
day what the [ __ ] else are you doing you
[ __ ]
that is supposed to be working out
during the lockdown delay
and true to his tweet at may 12th he
didn't do [ __ ] the director then decided
to shut down the production and he gave
patterson four weeks to go work out and
at least get toned
you have four weeks to look like batman
you got four weeks madison
four [ __ ] weeks get to it better be
in the gym
all day every day except for when you're
eating protein
obviously if batman is going to be
fighting criminals he has to at the very
least be
fit and bad it's more like a junkie than
a guy that rounds them up
that's just a great quote i don't care
if this is true it's a good
point cut to october 1st
we got some info last night paddington
is back and during his absence he still
refused to work out the director has
thrown up
his hands and is just going with it the
two stunt doubles are so
much bigger than patterson there's going
to be no doubt
when he is not in the suit as bruce
wayne looks like a stick
this could be a one and done movie they
have to reshoot all the footage we saw
in the teaser trailer
pattinson is a pain to work with he
whines about the suit it's hot it's
tight yeah everything we've heard about
pattinson in the past with all the crazy
performances given this totally lines up
at this point the director just wants to
get the movie done and move on this is
such a loaded [ __ ] yeah come
on guys he didn't realize that when he
got cast as bruce wayne he has
spent so much time with his suit you
know don't believe this
this is so funny i mean this is funny
this is really funny but it's a load of
crap
so according to the source someone with
direct knowledge of the production
pattinson notes ground director matt
reeves down
tennison looks ridiculous in the role
the summit are much
[Music]
batman is going to grow and shrink
throughout the movie
superpower oh yeah they can't digital
any of this ruse knows that this is a
problem but apparently he just wants to
get the albatross of a movie off his
neck if these rumors are true
they're not all right batman filming may
be delayed again
all right here we go hollywood writer
and director gary j
tunicliff confirms the batman robert
pattinson rumors
okay so an actual credible guy so he
didn't work on this movie
but he's worked on some big movies so
mainly works and makeup and effects like
what
humphrey said although he has directed
some
beloved hellraiser he's written a lot of
hellraiser movies and
cool so he's got he's got some
credentials this mofo all right
so here's what gary said all i heard was
that there were definitely
tensions between matt reeves and robert
pattinson that pattinson was
being quite difficult to work with the
person i had spoken to they almost
suggested that the situation was that
because i said i heard you shut down due
to covet and they said
it's not covid that shut us down then i
said
oh is it something else i said is it
your lead actor and they were like
maybe oh tuna cliff also talked about
the rumors of pattinson not wanting to
work
out and then of course i heard from
somebody else that the rumor was that
matt
reeves was visibly shocked at the size
of pattinson and that he was worried
that his stump people were considerably
larger than him so
obviously i looked into it with my
sources
you find out something for me and the
other rumors i saw kind of circulating
were there that they have an issue about
working out bulking up and everything
else
so gary went on to explain about yeah
this is nothing new danny jr with iron
man west assassin blade
actors cause problem if matt reeves is
having those
nasty situations with pattinson it can
make for very ugly filmmaking and the
stuff i did hear
that was that was the case and matt
reeves just wanted to get the thing
finished and get it done and get out of
there this just does
not lie i'm sorry to your best friend
gary
this is scary not lying it's okay man it
just doesn't make any sense to me
wouldn't that be
illegal to shut down a production first
off if that's a lie
over him getting coronavirus i don't
especially
warner brothers put that out i feel like
that would be illegal but they lie to us
all the time
the warner brothers put out an official
statement
yeah the thing is i don't know honestly
what the law is about that because it's
not false advertising necessary
let's put that to the side okay
everything we've heard
about matt reeves and his
the history of what we've heard elise
and the history of pattinson getting
involved this just doesn't line up
with it especially for me pattinson who
all puns intended went to bat to make
sure
he could become the batman he pursued
this role
this wasn't just like hey you want to do
it let me think about it like yeah
he pursued this role this doesn't line
up whatsoever the fact that there was
already
this beautiful footage the batman is the
best trailer all year
and you have plenty of moments with
bruce wayne and batman in there
and the footage looked fine physical
physically speaking it looked
fine like there was nothing about it
there's something jarring about cutting
back and forth between bulky batman
and robert pattinson as bruce wayne it
seemed perfectly fine this just seems
like a crazy rumor to capitalize on the
whole
not working out thing this would have
been problematic
of with from day one this would have
been a major problem
yeah it wasn't like coveted kicked in
and it was like you know i don't want to
work out
yeah yeah it's like if he wasn't down to
work out i feel like that would have
started from the very beginning i feel
like that would have been something that
he would have
he's too smart and plugged into the
current state of movies not to know that
he would be expected to at least
gain some amount of muscle and be
expected to
fill that suit that's and i'm sure
there's like contractual obligations
that he would
have to uphold he'd be looking at a
major lawsuit ahead of him the studios
would threaten him
if there was if he was this
non-compliant
this would be a disaster yeah it would
be and i mean
i don't know honestly what his actual
physical state is but i can also say
that like i think there is something to
the idea of not having a batman who's
just like
absolutely ripped cause like when you
see him in the suit i think he actually
kind of works that he does look a little
scrawny or at least not obviously
buff i'm just very very fascinated if
this is fake it certainly seems like
at least not the the truth not the
like god's honest truth i wonder w
what's going on because
to fake a corona fire like that just
sounds like such a ridiculous thing to
have to do there are a million
excuses you could use just to pause
production you could even just pause it
not tell us yeah
the most credible part of this would
have to be your buddy your best friend
yeah i'm standing by him gary j turner
coming in sticking vibe and that was a
great impression
saying that he spoke with someone
i spoke with somebody the whole thing is
just a game of television it literally
is
the whole thing is just a long game of
telephone he's not saying who he spoke
with tuna cliff
he could get that person in trouble he
pattinson he spoke
whoever he spoke with could just be
someone who is not enjoying
who might even just have his own
presumption his or her own presumption
this could just be someone who has
their own presumption of like you know
what i don't believe it i think we shut
down because robert
you know yeah yeah i mean a film set is
also yeah a big
community and there is also a game of
telephone that happens on a set
drama there's especially for a batman
set there's so many people on set
yeah a movie where you're already having
so much secrecy and protection around so
many of the things that you're shooting
that i would imagine that yeah not
everybody does have the full picture at
any given moment except for maybe matt
reeves and that's the other thing is
this idea
that he would just show up met uh rubber
pads in the first day
and have matt reeves be shocked at his
appearance i'm like you guys would have
had to have like interacted
yeah before this right i mean
they said rambling said at dc phantom
they shot like 30 to 35 percent of the
movie yeah exactly
so this would have been a problem
yeah and and i can't imagine his body
type
being the issue if his working out
during the
shutdown is the like
start of the process i would believe way
more about creative differences
versus this he seems like uh you know
he's got a certain temperament as an
actor i mean for the devil all the time
he refused to work with a dialect coach
because he wanted to find the voice
himself through the accent i don't know
there are things like that that i get
that are like okay i could see how you
would clash with your
you know creatives or whatever but i
don't know like again yeah like you said
he seemed very
invested in wanting to play this role
maybe there's a bickering about
how buff or not he is but yeah i can't
imagine that he's just like i don't care
i don't give a [ __ ] about this not gonna
put any professionalism
like he seems like he throws himself so
heavily into the work that all i could
imagine is maybe that's clashing somehow
with matt reeves
ideal take on the character but then
you're having a different issue
that isn't this petty [ __ ] that we're
talking about right now where it's like
uh pats didn't want to do it so we faked
corona and shut down so he could work
out for four weeks
well yeah exactly like a jack what the
hell is he gonna get done in four weeks
did he chub up is that the problem do
you need him to like shed some pounds
you can get results in four weeks i know
you can but it's not gonna take somebody
who hasn't worked out at all and turn
them into bad
to the point that it's gonna fix an
entire movie all right guys well
do you believe this try not to
and if we're wrong if this comes out
later on like down the line
at some point and there's zang that no
this is all true
and then they they'd have some weird
hollywood round table thing like kind of
what charlie is there and tom hardy
recently did for madame actually like
yeah i just refused
then all right i i i'm surprised but i
was wrong
right now i i call total [ __ ] the
source is pedro pascal
yeah that's who it is he's out there
he's like i want people to take their
attention off of me all right guys well
leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
last but not least let's do a
lance door look buddy i know you're
getting cold feet right now
but dude trying to postpone this wedding
by lying that you have coronavirus
is not gonna work for you man yeah you
need to work out for the wedding
you need a workout you need to get in
shape all right if you're expecting
your bride to be to be super banging
super fit
for her wedding dress you gotta stop
slacking yourself
quit using this pandemic as an excuse to
not get in shape
all right no one's buying it you can't
keep shutting down the wedding
just because you're being too lazy yeah
you can't show up on the first day of
the ceremony only to have your bride to
be just completely repulsed by your
scrawny
lack of investment in your love i know
you guys have already done
30 to 35 percent of the wedding but you
need to get to the i do's now yeah you
need to convince us
so lance quit making excuses
take more fiber poop man poop plants
poop you're gonna hold
you're batman to me